1 jour est également lâche à Kuruhama Ukokoro
Hinokage est Teru Sato
C'est un alter ego ouvert
fils de toi
Fais de moi ton apprenti, j'ai vaincu mon père
Je te le donnerai pour devenir Gravebori et Hokage
Je veux être Hokage
Il vaut mieux le mettre dès le début
J'ai demandé Sasuke
Tomori 8e place
S'il y en a, nous pouvons le faire
pourquoi vous souciez-vous de moi
J'allais plus souvent à Uratokachi qu'à Naruto
Parce que je peux veiller sur ta croissance en tant que père.
[ __ ] de club et deuxième place
ne pense pas que nous colorions
Les temps peuvent changer, mais l'essence ne changera pas
entrez simplement
Tu es à moi et tu es mon fusuku
Il y a
malt naruto le film
à l'est